i was like this is my moment i
it was everything that dreams could be
made of
and the final rose i mean dance
goes to caitlyn bristow and artem chig
vincent
i cannot even just hearing you say that
i'm like oh my gosh i
did we won
after 11 weeks in the competition the
former bachelorette and her pro partner
were named
the winners at the end of monday night's
finale
[Applause]
trophy right now the couple danced not
one
but two performances
[Music]
and both received perfect scores
[Applause]
gary cuff dan's our girl's best friend
bruno tom young and those tens across
the board
helped them beat out runners-up neve
shulman and jenna
and nelly and daniela who came in third
place and justina machado and sasha
who finished up in fourth place you know
what i was thinking i was thinking where
i was
a year ago exactly where i was not part
of last season
i thought that all dancing dreams was
done and dusted and
i'm never going to be able to perform on
that stage
at all so and then just standing with
caitlyn in the final
and being called as the champion of the
season i mean
it's it was such a surreal moment that i
never thought it would be even in
reality of this world
you know so just it yeah it's absolutely
crazy it made me so emotional because of
that
that you just never give up on things
and they come when you least expect it
caitlyn who has wanted to compete on the
show since 2015
following her time as the bachelorette
finally got her moment
and that patience well it paid off
i don't even know how to put it into
words but to me it's like
if you believe in something and if you
have a
passion or a dream no matter i mean
think about
every actor actress singer songwriter
anyone who's like gotten somewhere
i guarantee they have a story about what
it
what it took to get there so for me i'm
like
it makes it all so much better that i
had this dream that it was taken away
that i still believed in it that i
worked hard for it i stayed true to
myself through it
and that same thing with artem like what
he was saying like you just never know
when it's going to happen and the fact
that if just
everything aligned for us and that we're
here with the mirrorball like what
and both kaitlyn and artem agreed that
they might not have won the mirror ball
without that adversity
caitlyn i don't know do you say thank
you to the bachelor
for not letting you on before oh my god
yes
donations you do
i mean it's so i obviously
i i mean the word journey keeps coming
out but i
was on a journey with with the show with
the franchise
and just everything that's happened it's
like
i look back on it and i'm like i'm glad
i didn't go on the show five years ago
to get this
here today to be in a better place in
life to
have this experience with artem who's in
a different place in his life as well
like
uh yes i'm grateful for everything wow i
can look
back on it with gratitude who would have
thought the dancing duo has received a
whole lot of love on social media
following their big win like from
caitlyn's boyfriend
fellow bachelor nation star jason
tarting who
showed his reaction to the news in real
time
[Music]
so crazy oh my gosh i have to go home
and probably clean that up
oh my gosh that doesn't surprise me at
all
he also praised his girl on twitter
writing quotes
she freaking did it what a dream come
true from an amazing human that deserves
it
do you have a support system and people
who believe in you and don't make you
feel
like you know i just
sorry this is so rude of me to say but i
think about like five years ago if i
would have came on this show i'm like
i just would have felt guilty and this
let
this allowed me to be like in the moment
and present and live my dream
knowing that i had supported at home and
i think artemis probably
wouldn't give it the same way no i think
success like that only as
beautiful as people near you you know if
they if they make you feel like you
well deserve that and you can share that
with them it's
it makes it so much more precious so
much more
valuable and there is nothing can
replace that you know
this is just as good as biggest people
who is next to you yes
and artem's fiance nikki bella was just
as hyped
she shared this clip on instagram with
their baby boy mateo
he's bringing home the miramar trophy
what do you think of that
yeah i literally said like this is the
best 3dx in my life
three months old and a bit and he
literally like i feel like i understand
everyone
it's insane i watched that video and i
was like he knows he gets it
so how did they celebrate okay so people
want to know how we're celebrating
it's pizza nelly's beer
and the mere miracle with pizza and
nelly's beer what more could you ever
want
how are you feeling adam i'm feeling
great
i feel like we just did 705 interviews
we did we're a little
tired and how's this for good
sportsmanship
after nabbing that mirror ball trophy
caitlyn appeared to celebrate with neve
it's it's the consistency oh
all tens for me oh wow well it's the uh
i dreamed to be dumb
since i was a little baby for me she
shared
that clip on instagram writing in part
quote
neve you're a beautiful dancer and i
hate you
[Music]
xoxoxo